[Music]
hi everybody my name is Jason quack and
welcome to my breakout session on using
machine learning to meet general data
protection regulations so just a brief
introduction of myself in work I work as
the leak clock attack in Evelyn
solutions we are premier partner of
Google globally and now hick water solve
is in Sweden our specialties within GCP
I in infrastructure lift and shift we do
machine learning projects as well and we
also help the customers get the best of
us we experience now in the brief
session we're gonna cover a few topics
so what is gdpr and who does this affect
you understand GPR we have to understand
as well what is personal data then we're
going to talk about the protections
given by gdpr to EU citizens and next
we're gonna go through a few use cases
and how to use machine learning to
provide those protections so what is GDP
are so GDP are is a regulation that
protects personal data of you EU
citizens and the processing and movement
of the data as well so this regulation
actually goes into force 25th May of
this year as you might have remembered
from the 20 2010 onwards of me there was
many companies sending you emails we've
had enhance terms and conditions
requesting your consent to use your data
for their for their processing needs now
this the first step the GPR is attaining
consent now who does this affect this
affects any organization that collects
stores and processes personal data and
this is on European citizens so it
doesn't matter if you are from a US
company or your Asian company you will
have to comply these regulations as well
and any non-compliance actually covers
comes with a very huge fine
the fine can come to almost to four
percent of the annual revenue now let's
talk about personal data so leanness are
examples of personal data then
like your name your ID number or in the
US your social security number your
credit card number your email address
even your picture is data it belongs to
you now you can see I mean in many forms
you can sit a structured data in the
database or you can sit as a structured
data in your Google Docs your slides or
your spreadsheets and even your emails
now think about it this way data as we
know it now in GDP are the companies our
own your data anymore what you are doing
you're actually loaning your data to the
companies for them to use it and you
have the right to control that data we
should give them so this is what GDP are
is about so what are the main
protections given by GDP are to EU
citizens I like to I like to use it in
Manik here called the big rate right
I'll protect data so when you think
about GDP I think of a big rate Rhino
the B stands for breach notification
rate R stands for drive access the right
to be forgotten privacy by design as
well as data protection officers now
let's pick out a problem as a valid
solution right we have many many
services that we built for customers and
GDP R is approaching right we also we
have systems in gtp with data in Drive
we have posted a line drive where posted
data in cloud storage buckets in s3
buckets now what we need to do next is
to create functionality to allow user to
be forgotten completely from systems to
retrieve or a little information of a
user if the user requests for the
information we need to build breach
notification capabilities and we also
need to retain our systems with privacy
in mind now this is a lot of data we're
gonna handle so we look at GCP and we
see look at a health products they offer
things like pops up so we can handle
large amounts of data coming in we use
we leverage App Engine which is one of
the to me I loved App Engine because you
can fling up great web interfaces really
quickly which is a very great great way
to get input to train your machine
learning models we will leverage face
recognition technology as well and going
use of this open source
traditional models we can use to detect
faces to fulfill the right we can look
at the data loss prevention API as well
Google Drive API ice and we use a use
bigquery and stackdriver logging so this
was our strategy we're going to use as
much GCP products as we can to fulfill
the rights of to build these protections
or gdpr
so there can she meet the deadline of
25th May let's jump into a breach
notification what is a breach so when
you build systems on GCP right you have
you build your firewalls and you prevent
you could help prevent as you have
lowers right and Louis Commission's so
people cannot access the systems but how
do you actually take a breach how do you
know your system has been breached so
one of the tactics as well is using
machine learning to detect locks
intrusions difficult patterns so one of
our use cases were actually using TCP
dump it's a very simple tool the law all
DNS calls from servers and as well as
all workstations and you and we pipe all
this DNS URL of course into stack driver
and what's great about that is that
struck driver is Savalas so we can you
can handle as much low as you give it
basically so it also handled these
millions of calls that cannot kill on
the server on our workstation now using
a recurrent neural network with long
short term memory we can detect so ok
I'll leave your background on malware so
when a malware attacks you're wrong your
VMs right
why it does is it uses a domain
generation algorithm to try connectors a
command control server to get further
instructions to take a next step either
to destroy information or to hold ransom
so this was one of the tactics that's
used by the cryptolocker ransomware in
order to get for the instructions so for
example in your stack driver locks if
you see a domain name in a bottom left
corner there it means that your system
has been attacked by the cryptolocker
ransomware and it's infected the sauce
papers over here so what we did was that
we had trained this model using Empire
Engine and we provided the two source of
information
so the first sauce was using a top one
in websites they were real from Alexa
and as well as using the domain
generation algorithms that were cracked
already to generate large amounts of
training data of malicious DNS URLs and
what we do is that we training on mo
engine and we also put it on in the
cloud datastore where you detect there
is possible breaches and one thing about
ml models as well is that your unique
constant feedback in order to continue
this improve quality improve your model
so we also create a web interface on for
dev up guys because she go in and
classify any suspicious areas as benign
or malicious this is for probabilities
that are lower than say 60% so that we
actually continue to update the model
and improve it we also make use of clock
composer which is basically Apache
airflow the continuously training once a
week so there is updated on on fly as we
go along
so I'm gonna jump to a quick demo over
here on my screen so for this case we
have the malware DNS monitoring click on
it
para no Wi-Fi
you know Wi-Fi yeah
yep okay
sticking well great
so for that so all these locks are
actually going into sec driver right now
and we have also had locked the resource
names as well as the probability of it
being malicious dns called and what the
devil sky thing going to do actually is
just tag it's been a malicious is a very
simple continuously improving process so
for example let's just type in some
addresses here to classify so you took
at google.com for example so here's a
very low chance of being malicious let's
take a long address domain name justice
check whether is it length they were
talking about there's also a very low
chance of occurring so we take something
that I generated off domain generation
algorithm over here for cryptolocker you
see there's a higher probability of
being malicious so it's not just the
length is also the placement the
consonants we didn't evolve us and how
we detect that you pay using the neural
network to train it and get the right
detections so this one we can I usually
use machine learning to detect this
malicious DNS URLs can go into sites
could we go back to the slides Thanks so
next the right of access so what if the
right is the right of access so when a
person goes to your company and say give
me all the personal information you have
with your video systems to me the weave
gdpr you have to comply we didn't and
then we talked about how do you do it
how do you what do you I use a data fall
and and you actually have to give all
these data back in a readable form now
how do you do that when all your
information is stolen gee sweet and in
fact storage buckets and you have not
enough metadata to understand how do you
do it for pictures for maybe your
company photos we go for outings now
what we what we build actually we use
some Google Drive and we actually scan
through all the files and Google Docs
squishy
spreadsheets every time he has been
changed as well as PDFs and image files
first using Google vision API that also
has OCR capabilities as well so like
even your credit card number on a
picture is considered personal data as
well this is trigger using Google Drive
and Google Cloud Storage push
notifications they push the pops up and
then what we do is that we push it to
App Engine as a call we should call the
API and try to figure out is this
personal data or not to access this
right users have to go and supply they
actually supply their personal data to
search within system so for example for
me I submit a photo of myself going from
left to right top to bottom and then
this is used as a picture to scan for
order order
image files within soft storage as well
as Google Drive for the for me in it so
when new images are safe in the go
driving cloud storage they actually
first scan by Google vision API so they
can annotate on the faces so we find the
coordinates whether this photo has a
face in it or not the region the reason
is that we use Google vision API but I
serve a lot and handle massive skill
compared to using our open face models
directly the reason for that is it's
like I mentioned in Savalas
as well as much cheaper so we detect
there is a
we didn't image and this is images not
only store as JPEG but images that
thought we didn't a Google Doc or we did
a Google site so there are embedded
images as well we are talking about when
we detect there is a face we extract the
face find the coordinates crop it out
and use open face to get the vector
vectors of the face so your face becomes
basically a floating-point number vector
and we store it into bigquery the reason
we use bigquery is because it allows us
to search for these images in a very
good manner in a very fast manner as
well so we search for the lowest
including distance between say my face
and other other faces thought within
systems so any matches above a certain
threshold are dead start into cloud
datastore and you casually look at it
from the app and App Engine website as
well so now jump in a demo so you look
at the personal data search what I'm
gonna do is just submit my face over
here yes something I just took earlier
on yeah so I guess I try to you back
so why is doing now is vectorizing my
face give you a few seconds so why is
doing now in the background is actually
running getting my face data and then
using the we actually run open face as a
container on GK and then getting the
vectors out and then doing a query or
bigquery just refresh it just complete
it so what now you can see is that I
have some images on me that I actually
put out on a GC system and then you can
actually have the link the owner of the
images of the document as well and of
course there is a few other that is my
son so it's quite close but not that's
enough then some of my colleagues over
here in the bottom the bottom so what
you do normally you do a trash hole so
you can find the closest matches your
faces and then you can deliver it at an
inner document so we can open a document
here as well which is its lights you see
some tests here and this is how you look
like in bigquery
just run a curry
over here you can see that there's this
other house how basically your face
looks like as a vector can't change back
to the slice thanks thanks
so now the right to be forgotten so that
we're going to build the next step which
is the right to be forgotten by a user
so for example if a person answers a
question to a quiz and you store it in
you thing called Google Forms a story
into a spreadsheet now after after you
have entered a quiz and you've got a
price you actually can request to get
your data removed from the system so
there you can prevent direct marketing
and the end user organization actually
have to comply because if it is within
your rights to remove the information
but however the you the the company made
up may have used for the information as
well you want to keep track of maybe the
answer that you give so even though your
name identifies you maybe they read the
answer you give to the question does not
identify you
so that doesn't fall within the scope of
personal data so when a person submits a
request to be forgotten the DPO as she
go using appengine web interface to look
on to do a request for access invoke the
right access to get all the hits you get
back on your g suite and you're on your
buckets and what the DPO does is that it
will then make a few sticks few steps do
I remove the whole document because I
don't even know about in G suite as well
just version this version handling as
well for every single document you have
every single spreadsheet everything is
like there is versioning which means
that if you just remove the picture on
the latest version and you save it what
you can do again you could go back to
the previous version very easily and get
back the pictures again which means that
actually you have not really removed all
personal data from system and there's
actually something that is a kind of a
catch so once one one possible way is to
really remove the whole document if you
don't need the information next ties to
remove the relevant information now this
is a quite troublesome procedure because
what you need to do is recreate an
entire document removing the personal
data so we now we have automate
that so actually recreate and I talked
about but without the personal
information that the user has requested
for the room to be removed
okay replace the information with dummy
data audio maybe remove the ascenders on
the role so there's a few health
decision-making process here that if you
do as I do to actually take now what we
use for training a bottle actually is we
want to actually mean
imitate the DPO and try and see what
what kind of factors that does he take
in consideration to execute the next
steps so we look at feature Sophia's
number of words in a foul if it's a
large foul you cannot remove the whole
entire foul because you may need certain
information from the foul as well
maybe so there is a consideration when
it was last modified it was a very old
foul maybe you don't need it anymore
the type of personal information is it a
picture is your face in the picture then
maybe it does make sense to put a red
triangle in the picture and re-upload it
again covering one person's face maybe
just remove to an entire picture
directly the access rights of the foul
who has access to this false so if only
one person there's really left the
company then you know it's not really
you can just remove the document the
location of the foul
so what we do is we structure and hire
gee suite layout as well so that the
location of the file actually determines
and dictates what kind of where should
you keep different kinds of personal
information so the DPO actually will
make a decision and then that is trained
to this annual model and this mo model
is actually very is a very simple model
it's just a linear classifier to give
you like whether should we remove or we
should be rejected or replace the dummy
data so what happens is that the model
making suggestions to the web interface
and the DNA becomes life becomes easier
for DPO and right now we don't have
enough data to actually make this
decision automatically so what you're
doing now is actually just running a few
scenarios the generate training data so
that we can eventually automate the
system so when it comes to voguing the
right to be forgotten you can just
invoke it and we can make a decision
someone I just confirm it and you can
remove all these documents away okay so
I'm not gonna jump into privacy by
design
so with Google suite and Google storage
one of the awesome things you can do is
share files right you can share files
and you can here and give share pilings
you can add people in the groups but
with privacy by design what that kind of
means to us is that you have to kind of
think of privacy at the highest level
because we think about someone loaning
you a data let me say you're responsible
for it you have to you have make sure
that you don't share data irresponsibly
and cause a problem to a company so any
changes in the access rights of file
with personal data should be
investigated so now you mentioned one a
previous task was actually identifying
any documents with personal data right
so that is done now how do you
understand which is a dangerous access
right change
how do you do that so they get any
change in terms of access changes do we
actually use stand drive again then she
have inbuilt logging of any changes to
cloud storage objects which is great and
then this publish directly the pops up
you know any flows so well together
there it just took sus like one day to
just implement this this was so fast and
using Google Drive you can actually
subscribe to push notifications as well
so where every time there is a
permission change it was a update you
and tell you okay there is this yeah so
someone has these documents we shared
somebody so again we pipe it through
through two pops up into App Engine and
we also train a model and the mono
detect whether the access right change
is correct or not in this case that song
is binary only so some of the features
that we use we use who do you share the
files to for example in GCS you can
share for you can share objects into a
to a service account or do you share or
you share to a group of users so this
obviously check the group of users just
mean it means that you can do that but
is that is that access right violation
so if you share personal data to a group
you know you better do it carefully the
location file like I mentioned we
restructure our power of our storage so
that we can put personal data in the
correct places a job title and come on
the user who found out actually quite
quite useful as well for example the
marketing department as I have to have
access to the CVS that HR half right but
the manager of market department may
need access to the CVS so we found out
that that's quite interesting feature
that we use as well as well as they are
the current permissions that user has so
we've dead we just change we just train
a linear regression model and actually
comes back and tags any changes in the
access rights as polished as possibly
correct or incorrect and therefore that
you can go in and more into this SS
right changes as well and you see and if
if you see like a large amount of SS
right changes being made like I also
detect that and flag that as a possible
violation so the last thing I wanna talk
about is as the data protection officer
so GCP is a data processor right so the
company using the GCP is the data
controller which in this case is us
Evelyn solutions so what is every single
company need to do you need designate a
data protection officer that many
basically handles all issues we've put
with the data and the protection of
personal data so this means that the DPO
can be very very busy okay they have to
train their users as well how to whether
store the personal data now i mentioned
there is locations of where you should
store your personal data in which in
which power which directory and also to
answer some questions or GPR and some
company's specific questions so for this
we use dialogue flow to build a chat bot
so that our employees can she go in and
ask questions about gdpr
and whether is this personal data or not
so a few examples we we go is like for
example we have we run workshops on
communities workshops so yeah so you
guys should go into the DPO chat bot ask
where should i say if the signup lists
the spreadsheet so even though you train
your you training people about how to
use we're just saying it where you save
personal data you can also on the fly us
the DPO chat box a you should save it
into this directory you show you share
it to this this person and this group so
that you don't [ __ ] you know actually
leaked out
or your usernames or your email
addresses questions we often often get
from our employees is if the username
consider personal data in any way often
I have many discussions about that but
the the so we can answer to you as well
the pseudo anonymous data is actually
considered personal data as well because
there can be linked back from a Google
search because may be of many a lot of
people use dashita usernames in many of
different platforms so you can trace
back to say facebook or any social media
profiles and leaking the true identity
so this is called consider personal data
as well so in conclusion while trying to
show is that the GPR work kind of things
that we did when we use AI to kind of
solve it it was called like you think
about it who wants that work on
compliance right it's kind of in kind of
a dry topic but we have found a way to
use of the latest technologies in the
out then in go cloud and in know all the
car spy things up so you can learn
things on the fly as well to learn
machine learning as well if you go along
and it's our test where does it actually
work and the best way to understand
whether it works is by using it so we
see that it does benefit we do save a
lot of time classifying this information
and tracking this potentially harmful
violations and so there we can she go
out and be under cool stuff so yeah
that's all I have my email address is
here Jason quite Evelyn solutions calm
so if any questions you know feel free
to drop me a mail and we can discuss a
bit more about how we build some of
these solutions and things you have to
think about to to make sure that your
organization is protected in gdpr Thanks
[Music]